next question I have over here is are
humans
monogamous
no
no everybody said no
unanimously everybody that wants a guy
to be committed to them said no
unanimously to amend I know it's iric
hum being monogamous that's that's
interesting I guess you were talking
about the
dream versus um reality the reality it's
not the human nature yeah yeah it's not
in human nature so why do women try to
enforce it
then
control no family yeah
family Ellen what do you say are you
just noding to I would say yeah when it
comes to family um because then that way
you know um that there's some level of
stability in your life and for the
family that you have so
MH I honestly I think it comes down to
um a little bit of control in a way
because you can't stop somebody from
Desiring someone else you can't stop it
they they have their thoughts anyway
whether they're going to do do it or
not and it's an ego hit if your man
finds another woman attractive um and
you can't stop it you can't you can't
stop it if it he might regret it and
realize how much he has to lose if he
stepped out and he got caught and
whatever but if I don't know anything
about it I don't want to know about it
because I don't want to feel jealous I
don't want to feel threatened I don't
want to feel those
feelings but if I don't know anything
about it I don't know but I understand
it's still a human nature I have
eyeballs too and I have feelings as well
I've been in long-term monogamous
relationships where I'm you know looking
at one of his friends and I'm thinking
hm you know I didn't do it but the
thoughts are there like we're all human
beings so I really think it comes down
to I'm gonna watch everything you do I
want to look at your phone I want to see
where you are and like I mean I know
girls you would want to look at his
phone you would want to degrade him to
the point where you want to look at his
phone no no no don't but I know girls
that that do that okay you're speaking
from the third got it I understand okay
and you wanted to say
something yeah she said she said control
and then she said you can't stab it so
you can control it well that's it he can
force h a man to be to be faithful but
the control part is the
trying you can't control anyone but you
can try if if he forcing he gonna
mhm
well go ahead M women women don't find
other men attractive or look at other
men if they're with a guy that they're
head over heels in love with when a
woman is in love with a man and she's
and that's the best that she can do
every other man on the planet is
invisible so anytime I ever hear a woman
saying like oh like I really love my
husband or I really love my boyfriend
but this guy gives me attention at work
and I think about him like that's over
it's already over it doesn't matter you
don't have to act on it um she doesn't
have to step out she doesn't have to
give the guy attention the fact that she
that that has been broken to this point
where she's even considering the
attention of another man I think there's
a spectrum there
too I don't what's the Spectrum I think
it's for men I don't think it I don't
think it exists for women in in the
beginning in the beginning no you don't
have eyes for anyone else like you're
completely in love you're in the
honeymoon phase or whatever but you've
been together for 20 25 years and you're
not sleeping together like you used to
anymore you're not doing things like you
used to together anymore and sometimes
people Veer away from that love even
though they love each other so much like
family even like you just can't live
without the person but when the dynamic
changes enough to a point where your
feelings also change you you fell in
love with the person they were doing it
should but it shouldn't be normal but
it's we're trying to unnormalized that
we don't think that women and men should
be a part we want men and women to be
together part of what rich and I do but
but can
right men can difference sex and love
woman can what I'm what I'm trying to
get to though what I'm trying to get at
is that there's this prevailing
sentiment that on a long enough timeline
two people are just going to end up not
loving each other anymore or they're
just gonna get bored one another and I
think that's I think that's a cop out I
think that there's I think that too many
men spend their time in front of the TV
watching the game and drinking beer and
eating food and they're not doing they
think once they get the ring on the
finger and the roof over the head and
the baby in the belly that's it game
over they've won not living like we
should be we're not living like we
should be life is way too easy
everyone's getting fat everyone's
getting lazy everyone's like you know
you know throwing out the poor mes and
I'm oppressed and I'm this and we are
living in a really effed up world right
now it's not the same like it used to be
we're supposed to be living in smaller
communities uh raising children busy on
the farm we're too busy to even look
outside and now we've got phones we've
got tablets we've got the TV we've got
everybody everywhere and it's just it's
raining all over the place and it's like
for men men can step out and have you
know I don't have eyes for anyone else
but my woman that's okay but a woman
who's also a human being who's also
exposed to all of these outside
influences can't like it or else anymore
it doesn't make any sense does different
because men and women are completely
different yes we are different but we're
a lot the same too I I agree right same
we are different but we're talking about
a fundamental difference here okay but
we're also human beings living in a
world that we shouldn't be living in our
society today is not right we we can't
we can't create
you can't rify society as this thing
that's not made up of us and our actions
and our habits we Society doesn't exist
in a vacuum like we're all a part of it
right so it's it's something that we've
created or we've had a hand in doing so
what we're trying to do is let me ask
you a question Lor out of that cycle let
me ask you a question why do you get
jealous I actually don't feel a lot of
feelings of jealousy I I don't feel that
a lot okay so why do you fear him
stepping out on you
because I don't want to start over again
okay because he's going to do
what um possibly fall in love with
someone else and leave me not be
attracted to me there it is okay so
women get jealous because they fear
losing the guy because the other woman
will draw draw him in take your love
that you have with him away from you
that means that you lose a guy you lose
his protection you lose his skills his
ability his influences Social Network
all that sort of stuff why do you think
men get
jealous why do I think men get jealous
because they don't want a man stealing
his woman away either see you use the
exact same mindset like the exact same
lens that you view the way that you get
it's not the same it's not okay so
explain it to me then a little bit men
see well when women get pregnant you
have 100% Assurance of paternity right
you know that that child in your belly
is yours M the man
doesn't he is so when a guy steps out
what's the first question that you ask
do you love her where did you take her
stuff like that
right you know what ask did you [__] her
how many times did you [__]
yeah right so that's you know so that's
the biggest differences right so that's
just one example between men and women
it's ego thing yeah it's an ego thing
yeah for for you know for guys like
they'll ask questions like did you have
sex with him how many times did you have
sex with him did you blow him did you
swallow did you have an orgasm like
they'll start asking very intimate
questions whereas for women they're like
well do you love her right well yeah why
did you take her to that restaurant
because we go to that restaurant right
like those are the things that go
through wom's mind because they don't
want to lose the guy to a gal because
they because they know that that's how
they
how they feel about him but for guys
it's like why did you have sex
right and they want to know the details
around that so those are that's just one
example the differences between the way
that men see these things versus the way
that women see these things and I get it
like I totally get you know the
importance of these things because like
you say we're not here to build
skyscrapers in roads and do podcast and
stuff like this like we're here to
scatter se you know we lived as nomadic
hunter gatherers for a very very long
time and and if uh loar of the Hill
People didn't come back from the
saber-tooth tiger hunt because he died
there was a very real risk that the
women that he was taking care of would
potentially die right like her and her
children may not make it if he were to
you know disappear back then there was
uh you know there was no monogamy like
monogamy is a very modern sort of
concept and humans really aren't really
built that way it's like you know women
were shared with men in the highest
value men would get the most women sort
of thing and it's still kind of that way
you know to this day still too right
like some of the most successful guys
usually have more than one woman like
it's kind of common I think Anna would
sort of you know correspond with this
especially in parts of Europe and
Eastern Europe and around the
Mediterranean like the most successful
guys might be married but they probably
have a mistress too right yeah or they
make a lot of children sure cuz I mean
you could have a Island full of men with
one woman and you wouldn't be able to
repopulate that island but if you had
one man with a whole bunch of women on
that island you could repopulate the
entire Island very easily with one
man right so I mean there's some big big
differences
there oh yeah for
sure I agree too and I I believe that um
the acceptance of U men stepping out is
um more common than it's more shameful
for a woman to do it than it would be
for a man and I I believe that I really
do I I would be completely ashamed if I
did that and and uh to my man I wouldn't
be able to do it at all but I would
probably forgive him if he did it to me
Well it Well if you do it then it's over
like that's what M's Point like if you
step out on the relationship it's like
women really can't like there's no time
in history where women have run a Herm
of men you know where they've had like
multiple husbands or multiple men
simultaneously whereas um in recent
history I think it was in the 1800s he's
in the Guinness Book World Records
ishmail the bloodthirsty who was a
Moroccan Sultan had uh multiple wives
multiple
concubines uh he would turn men into
Unix to guard his women he had well over
a thousand children right um there's no
example of this in history where women
have had you know multiple men
simultaneously they just don't do it
because women pair bond and they get
imprinted on by a guy and they usually
stay with that guy if he's a top shelf
guy right like women women will deal
with one man at a time whereas a man can
deal with multiple women
simultaneously the problem that we have
today is a lot of women are like oh well
guys are dealing with multiple women so
I should deal with multiple women
because men and women are the same and
when women do it then they just ruin
themselves like they they get mess in
the head I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clip's from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out